for those that are new to the research
fellowship program
i want to briefly give you the
background the purpose
and the structure of this program so
that everybody's on the same page
this session is also going to be
recorded so please
be aware of that we're going to be
sharing the recording with others that
are
not able to join today and as sonalika
mentioned
for those of you that are new that have
recently joined the research fellowship
program
we would love to get to know you to
learn a little bit about your background
why you joined what is your interest and
how do you plan to use the time
in the research fellowship to work on
your independent research project
but because we do have a lot of people
that are new to this
i want to start off by just kind of
briefly and i will try to really
keep it short but kind of go over the
major
parts of the program how it is organized
and then i will pass it on to
somalila and dr harpridka or
to guide the session for today's
presentations
so let me start by kind of introducing
you to
our background who we are so uh
as you all know omix logic is a
bioinformatics
training portal that has been developed
by
this collaboration that we have between
pine biotech
and the talbot bioinformatics research
center which is a research center
at the university of haifa but over the
years we have
had the chance to work with students
researchers and
clinicians from many different
institutions from around the world
and as a result we now have this global
community
that has over 10 000 participants from
all around the world
and we have gone through many steps of
iteration
to make sure that our program is
structured
and well prepared for the needs of those
that are interested in
bioinformatics and data science in
application to a variety of different
biological
and biomedical challenges so we have a
dedicated team
in india we also have a number of pilots
that we have done
at different universities and our
background is that we have done
a lot of in-person workshops as well as
different types of online programs that
we've conducted
uh in the past couple of years we also
have a dedicated team
in africa that is spearheaded by
our team in nigeria and we also have a
number of
other participants from other different
countries
and we have been trying to work with the
local and regional partners that we have
to make sure that our content and
materials are well adapted to the needs
of these local participants and so we
think that we've gotten very positive
feedback
and we've conducted these again in india
in africa and obviously also in the us
so in the us our major partner is the
louisiana biomedical research
network but also georgetown university
and others and so what this allows us to
do
is to really bring you the best
materials from all of these locations
consolidated and adapted to an online
experience
leveraging our experience offline and
kind of trying to facilitate this
process of research and discovery using
bioinformatics
and so the outcome that we see as a
result of this kind of
training is the ability to
guide and help complete
research projects conducted by faculty
teams of people as well as individuals
so the research fellowship combines
access to big data which means
big data resources as well as
tools to analyze and process big data
mentorship which is both experts
trainers
and peer example as well as access to a
variety of
training resources for asynchronous and
live training
and so what we are trying to address
here is
the problem of helping people access
resources for big data analysis
mentors that can help match the right
kind of analysis methods
to their research question and a
community that will keep you accountable
and provide you with
feedback so that you are prepared to
work on impactful topics
and develop your research projects until
the very end when you are ready to
present
and so this comes with a lot of program
resources that we've developed that we
think could be very helpful for all of
you
now we tried to combine all of these
resources on our onyx logic training
portal that has a variety of different
types of asynchronous courses as well as
more guided programs that are led by
experts in bioinformatics and we provide
for
all of the participants of this program
access to specific
sessions that you can access to
understand whether that program is right
for you
and this is typically done in
collaboration with other universities
and organizations
so not only do you get the opportunity
to learn about the topic but also
interact from particip with participants
from these different institutions
but you can find all of this on our
omixlogic portal which is
[Music]
learn.omixlogic.com you will find there
adapted courses for you personally based
on your experience
as you progress that will change you
will be able to track your progress
and see how you've improved your
understanding of the basic topics
as well as the application of these
different tools
in different types of challenges and
projects like this
is an example of a project on the origin
and pathogenesis
of the novel coronavirus and we have
many other examples like that as well
so behind this what we also provide is
access to user-friendly big data
analysis tools and this is a critical
component of this program
you get access to five terabytes of
storage which allows you to process and
analyze large data sets that allow you
to use
advanced statistical methods and machine
learning
as well as multi-omics integration and
several tools that will be helpful for
biological interpretation now this
infrastructure is limited we do not give
everybody
access to that same resource and the
research fellows that have joined this
program
have that kind of a special level of
access where you can actually
conduct a full research project but you
have to coordinate it
with us and so what that allows you to
do is to
explore a data set and find the right
methods to apply to a research
question so the objective of this
research fellowship
that i will briefly discuss today is to
start from training and then guide you
to complete some of the training
resources that i've identified
create a sense of understanding and
practical skills and then to apply that
to a number of research
problems now the best way to get started
is to really take a look at a variety of
projects that we already have
available and these range from topics in
biomedical applications to biotechnology
to a variety of human health related
topics
as well as more advanced topics in
cancer
biotechnology agriculture
neurodegeneration
if infectious diseases and ultimately
any other topic that you would like to
focus on but it's important to come to
that topic prepared
to really be able to understand how
experts work on projects
to understand how to find data sets to
specifically identify
a research question and then find the
right tools and so
the research fellowship is really an in
silico
research experience where you have
three to six months typically some of
you i know have joined for only two
months but typically is going to be from
three to six months
and you're able to work as a part of a
structured program and today's session
in
is one of these examples where you
hopefully come away with a clear
understanding of what
the program does and how it's organized
so that you can navigate the different
resources
with ease so a critical point of that
is this structure that we've developed
that is divided up
into three parts first there's the
introduction where you get the
introduction to bioinformatics theory
methodology
and applications you get to use some of
the cloud tools for big data processing
and also complete some of the
introductory coursework
then it's the evaluation where you start
to
analyze literature from other
publications and
other data sets to understand how to
develop a research proposal
and then one once you have done that you
can apply the
tools that you've learned how to use to
a problem
of your own to help guide you through
that process we have
two specific channels that help
us help you one of those is our slack
channel so at this point can i ask
everyone that's present today how many
of you that are actually a part of the
research fellowship
have joined the slack channel
okay if you have joined the slack
channel please put in the chat yes
or one or something like that okay thank
you
all right excellent
okay thank you everyone so if you have
not gotten
access to the slack channel i see
nandita aishwarya
if you have already applied for the
research fellowship and received your
acceptance letter
you should be added to the slack channel
so please reach out
to marketing at pine bio and so malika
who is here today with us
will be able to add you there the second
important part
and so malika maybe you could be in
contact
with the people that said no make sure
that if they have applied and
uh gotten their access they should be a
part of that
okay so i would want to add here that i
have sent you all the
invitation already for the slack channel
please check your
mail ids and then you'll get your
invitation there and then you can join
i'll send it out again
thank you thank you
and the second one is this weekly
progress report
form so once you are a part of the
research fellowship
and you would like to discuss any
updates
technical challenges or questions that
you might
have before weekly session you have to
submit the weekly progress report form
okay so i've seen a few of you have
submitted that form today
typically you would want to submit that
form
a few days before the session so that
our team can prepare and address the
specific questions that you have or if
you have a presentation
that you want to share your progress
report with us
we can help you address any kind of like
immediate questions and so
i will talk a little bit about the
presentation here in just a second as
well
the second part is access to these
publicly available data sets so when you
collect
raw data for your project
you have to be familiar with what this
data represents
okay so a big mistake that many people
make is the first data set that they
come across they start working on that
data set
before you start analyzing anything the
reason why we ask you to submit this
progress report is that we want to know
that you are trained
and ready to analyze a particular type
of data
and also that you have explored the data
metadata
so how do you explore the metadata
typically that means
you have to read the paper and in the
paper you will find that associated data
set but
in the paper they also describe how did
they generate the data set
why did they generate it what were the
questions that they were asking
and that typically results in a specific
design
that helps you extract from there the
types of comparisons and contrast that
you would be able
to do in your own research project so
typically
you also have to perform exploratory
data analysis
so that you can understand the
variability
in the data set and oftentimes people
will end up using multiple data sets so
you have to be familiar with methods to
normalize your data
explore your data address any kind of
technical variation and only then
ask that specific question so hopefully
the tools that we provide
will be sufficient for you to be able to
do that quickly
now after that after that not before
that but after that
you choose a topic right and in that
topic
you want to be very specific and find a
topic that is compelling
and interesting to the audience that you
will present right so
you have to have the data set available
you have to understand
what is the background and then you also
have to do literature
review to understand where is that
specific topic that you would like to
focus on for the next three to six
months if you do that
before you've explored the data before
you've read the literature
you're not going to be able to find an
impactful topic that you can actually
work on
so here we provide specific training and
i'm not going to do this today but
you've probably seen this in previous
sessions and if you have not
you can request that recording or you
can also
join one of our upcoming sessions where
we will do this kind of training where
we go through
how to perform literature review how to
identify a specific
topic of interest how to ask a research
question and ultimately how to translate
that
into a particular question or hypothesis
that you can work
on and that's where your mentor really
comes in
so as a result of analyzing your
activity
on the onyx logic portal and as a result
of
looking at the specific coursework that
you have completed
uh the articles that you have submitted
in the research proposal
and other things our mentor will be able
to use that time
effectively so we don't want to use the
mentor time for just going through the
very basics how to open excel how to
install r
how to find a data set things like that
that's where
these weekly meetings are for the mentor
session
is to help you address the specific
question that you might have
and make it more impactful
and so for that we've developed this
step-by-step process
where you identify a topic you find a
data set
you make a table of metadata and you
explore your data
and then when you conduct your analysis
you put all of that
into a shared presentation and that
presentation should be shared with your
mentor that presentation is where we can
find
all of the updates that you're making
and see how you're making progress so
that we can help
get you unstuck in technical issues and
also
point your attention on the most
interesting
aspects of your data set when you
present to the mentor you're not only
presenting to the mentor you're also
presenting to the peer community
that is all a part of this research
fellowship so today we will hear
a number of these project presentations
we will give
feedback but also we ask that you ask
questions
you pay attention to the presentation
and you think about
how is this project addressing the
specific need or
question that was proposed at the
beginning of that question right so that
process of information exchange and
participation is also a critical part of
this program
once you incorporate all that feedback
then you can finalize the presentation
and potentially identify
a poster presentation or a research
journal for peer review that you would
like to submit
and that's something that we will talk
about today how to make your
presentation
impactful and organized so that it is
making sense and it is effective at
conveying the story
when you process the data for analysis
it's important to understand that some
of these data sets are
huge and when you go through these data
sets you have to follow a specific
process
and so that's where the training is very
important
but beyond getting the basic data set
organized and prepared you then have to
be able to explore the data and that's
why we also provide you with training
on how to use basic tools like excel
r python and different online tools that
you can leverage
to explore the data set that you have
selected and make sense of it so please
leverage some of the tutorials that we
have on the learnomicslogic.com portal
and that will help you deal with that
data set
once you perform the in-depth analysis
we have several
experts that can help in a
variety of different topics for
transcriptomic data
for structural data for genomic data for
different parts we can match you with
somebody that can help
answer your specific questions you have
to let us know so remember that it's
your responsibility to reach out to us
and let us know what is it that you're
interested in doing
and how we can best help you finally
when you get to this process
of preparing your analysis results
you are going to be also following
examples of many others that have gone
through the same process
and so that's where your peer community
is going to be very helpful
so when you present and you go through
these iterations
of drafts you will see that we can help
you the most by
making that presentation better and
helping you
present something to external evaluators
at poster presentations if you're
looking to submit a research article
in a much more prepared way and so the
outcomes
of this process are very important to
keep in mind right so have a goal when
you're joining this program have a
specific goal
you will have a guarantee and a positive
outcome if you properly identify
what that outcome for you is maybe you
just want to understand
the specific challenges and data sets
and gain training
that's one option maybe you want to
develop some skills like processing data
and analyzing data maybe you want to
join
an independent project or a group
project so that's another option you
don't have to work on this on your own
we will hear today from root v who has
completed an independent project and
hopefully she will continue to work on
a group project next so some people will
actually announce
that i'm working on this topic and i'm
looking for collaborators
that's why it's important to be a part
of the slack channel in our community
so that everybody can get to know each
other not only hear their presentations
in the final results
so let me briefly tell you what are some
of the recent examples
of people that have successfully
completed the research
projects and the research fellowship
april zhang just recently completed a
research fellowship
she's a high school student and now she
got accepted to
berkeley for bioinformatics
undergraduate
and we have a recording of her
presentation that you can take a look at
i'm gonna post
uh the link right here
see mine dolaner she will be presenting
in the next uh core in the next
psionics session that will happen
uh i believe tomorrow but i will let uh
rudy talk about that in a little bit
uh supantha who is from bangladesh
and he is uh also you can see his
project presentation he will also be
presenting at the cyanux club
uh dr anita ganza uh who is right now
working still on a number of research
projects together with
uh her team and we have collaborated
with her and her
team to recently present her project
at the louisiana biomedical research
network
so please take a look at some of these
links and you'll kind of see
how this works for some of the other
people that you might
be following in their footsteps and all
of them
are of course going to be available as
somebody that can give you
hints and tips and maybe some guidance
on
how to complete a project and make it
impactful
so that's an important part of the
outcome as well when you think of
completing this project think about how
are you going to use it to also advance
your personal career and learning
and so we have an example of urja that
finished her
uh project a while back andres
who has completed his project and will
be presenting next week
we have others that are uh selected to
be a
part of this program and so please do
share that information with others
with your network to help them
understand what you are working on
so now let me pass this on to
uh dr harpreed or sonalika i don't know
who is going to announce
who is going to be presenting next so
that you can kind of see
where this process will lead you as you
join this research fellowship